so Gary lineker will be back on our
screens next week after three days of
turmoil and a mutiny at match of the day
the BBC has quickly reinstated its
highest paid star the corporations
apologize to viewers for the crisis well
I'm very sorry for the disruption today
it's been a difficult day and I am sorry
that audiences have been affected and
they haven't got the programming it says
it will carry out an independent review
into its guidelines on the use of social
media Sky Sports News also understands
that the BBC apologized privately to
Gary lineker have you come to any sort
of agreement with the BBC at Mr linica
but all this has come at what cost in
its pursuit of impartiality some say the
BBC has called into question its own
independence
so how did the BBC get into this mess
and can it ever get it right I'm Sally
Lockwood infernil Patterson and this is
the Sky News Daily
well I mean the BBC is never on to go
the BBC has been around for 100 years
and has a collection of wounds that
would you stretch from here around the
globe I mean you know if you're as big a
broadcaster as the BBC you're going to
have all kinds of things happen and some
of them are unquestionably embarrassing
uh and one would rather wish they hadn't
happened but the BBC is there after 100
years for a reason it's been an
embarrassment but I think there's a way
forward and I'm optimistic that
something at the end of this will be
resolved this is Mark damism he has a
vast knowledge of the inner workings of
the BBC he was formerly the boss of
Radio 4 and before that he was the head
of current affairs head of political
programs an editor of its television
news
we're going to be talking to him later
about where the BBC goes from here but
first this route over Gary lineker's
tweets has become a huge deal because
it's made people think twice about the
BBC's Independence and its role in
politics when Tim Davey became the BBC's
director General he made impartiality
the corporation's core value we are in
the BBC and myself are absolutely driven
by a passion for impartiality not left
right or pandering to a particular party
I think at the moment it's a
ridiculously big crisis I mean for
something to lead the news day in day
out right across the media on the BBC
and and everywhere else is uh is
absolutely bizarre Suzanne Franks is a
media professor at City University and
before that she was a BBC News producer
to you know to immediately react and
cancel much of the day or cancel Gary
lineker um is is is extraordinary I mean
I can't see that another organization
would have would have I mean it's like a
panic panic attack um I don't see that
another organization would have done
that we have to give it to the BBC that
that they have had this story running at
the top of their news bulletins they've
scrutinized themselves uh in recent days
they've also you know had phone ins
about it on on five live but do you
think they also kind of got themselves
into a pickle over this Gary lineker
issue and impartiality
well they've completely got themselves
into a pickle and personally I I would
have um also challenged the news
judgments that that puts this at the top
of the bulletin um day I mean not not
just for one day but sort of day after
day last week explain to us if you can
just why it is so important for the BBC
to be perceived as impartial well I
think to to be able to kind of sustain
your your crucial reputation as a public
service broadcaster as the broadcasting
you know on behalf of the public to the
public paid for by the public
um you have to be seen to represent All
Points of View and to be fair between
different different points of view but
that that's really predominantly
something that that matters in in news
and current affairs and it's very very
important there that round the world the
BBC is is seen as seen as impartial and
that's how it's kind of value and
reputation you know over a hundred years
has been sustained but I think what
we're talking about here is is slightly
different because we're talking about a
sports reporter and if he was to be um
partial between I suppose different
football teams then we'd think oh you
know that that that's not really
acceptable but but we're not talking
about sport we're talking about his
personal Twitter account
um just talking about the the Affairs of
the day which is something else Suzanne
if Gary linear had expressed
anti-migrant views on Twitter in line
with the government's policy potentially
do you think we'd have seen the same
Fallout no I mean as long as they were
in sort of when you talk about
anti-migrant views yeah no If he if he
talked about you know that we need to
curb Asylum seeking us on or something
like that
um because I think the um
I think the BBC is
you know at the moment more than usually
very very nervous about uh what what the
government is is saying and what the
government thinks of them does the BBC
sometimes get it wrong by being so
bogged down in trying to be impartial
the David Attenborough series for
example you know an episode focused on
the destruction of Britain's nature
that has reportedly been pulled because
it could have risked a backlash from the
right-wing press and and toy politicians
and many would say
you can't be impartial when it comes to
issues like climate change impartiality
is also about calling out things that
aren't true rather than giving each side
the air time to say what they like well
I think climate change is a really good
example because
um a few years ago uh climate change was
held up as a you know it's an issue like
every other and we need to do on the one
hand and one on the other
um and the former um cabinet minister
Nigel Lawson who's a well-known private
skeptic was so many times on the BBC
voicing his views whereas thousands of
scientists were voicing the other side
and the BBC was trying to maintain this
um this this sort of what turned out to
be a false balance and then there was an
inquiry into this and they did reach the
Judgment which which you've just
referred to that you know you can't be
um neutral about about things climate
change is not something you can be
neutral about so that that is quite
interesting that uh that the BBC has you
know they did take a view and then they
they very much changed their view so I
I'm not quite sure if they pulled this
episode I mean I think what they're
saying now is this episode was never
going to be broadcast it was always just
going to be on iPlayer BBC denied that
the episode was ever going to be aired
anyway yes just lastly formerly a BBC
Insider looking in from the outside now
Suzanne
what does the BBC need to do I think it
needs to have the courage of its
convictions
um you know they shouldn't have I mean
basically that what happened last week
was driven by Daily Mail headlines you
know there were the daily man headlines
two or three days running and somebody
must have panicked in inside the BBC and
they they need to have the courage of
their convictions as a world-renowned
phenomenal fantastic public service
broadcaster that has you know he's got
this this amazing reputation over a
century and that they need to just stick
to their convictions and not worry about
what uh a right-wing newspaper and a
right-wing
um MPS are are muttering there
so Suzanne thinks the BBC needs to be
bolder and less influenced by criticism
hard in this case when Gary lineker's
suspension from match of the day
resulted in a boycott by Sports pundits
but marked Amazon who was previously
head of Radio 4 and a number of other
BBC News departments is philosophical
about the lineaker affair he's seen much
bigger crises at the corporation come
and go I think the Gary lineker Saga
their finest hour is a book unlikely to
be written about this I don't think it's
up there with Martin beshear and
Princess Diana
or the BBC and the Blair government
about weapons of mass destruction or
Jimmy Savile being sexual predator
whilst being allegedly some kind of star
on the BBC so I don't think it's
anything like those it's not their
finest hour but I I think that Tim Davey
was faced with a series of unpalatable
choices and actually is coming up with
what seems to me to be the most sensible
outcome but this is of course nothing
new I mean we've seen other stars
expressing views before Andrew Neil Alan
sugar he was very anti-jeremy corbyn you
had prolith who supported brexit
but the concern is that it's perceived
the BBC reacted in the way they did
pulling Gary lineker off air because
they bowed to pressure from government
ministers and that's the problem isn't
it why Paul why pull Gary lineker offer
and not discipline the other stars I've
mentioned now look Alan sugar this
guideline that we're talking about is
only 2020.
and you're quite right that some of the
tweets that Alan sugar had offered to
the nation before 2020 would have fallen
on the wrong side of this guideline in
my view but as it turns out uh I'm told
and you know I haven't done a forensic
examination of Sugarland but I'm told
that since 2020 and this guideline was
introduced he's actually turned it down
but Andrew Neal I mean it is a very odd
case it's very very few people on either
the left or the right think that Andrew
Neal was anything other than scruplessly
impartial as well as being well informed
on air and that's the get out it's not
very satisfactory by the way I can see
entirely the point that you make it's
inconsistent and imperfect and you're
right but it is an explanation he was
amazing on air Gary doesn't have the
ability to be impartial on air about
using current affairs that's not what
he's paid for he's just a consummate
Sports presenter so the same doesn't
apply but the BBC has another problem
doesn't it in that it has staff working
the BBC with with political Association
so you've got Richard the chairman who
donated to the Tories
the director General Tim Davey who once
stood to be a local councilor for the
conservatives and then he formerly
editor of political programming Robbie
Gibb who worked for Theresa May it
doesn't invoke a lot of trust does it
and public confidence is the BBC's
currency
well you're right about that public
confidence is the currency but I mean
each of those cases is slightly
different in and of itself Richard
Sharp's connections with the
conservative party is not what is
damaging in Richard Sharp's current
position let's say uh Tim Davey uh I
mean we're talking about something 30
years ago and I worked with Tim and I
can say that I never had a scintilla of
doubt about his commitment to the
independence and impartiality of the BBC
not at all Robbie Gibb um the BBC has
had people with political very obvious
political flavoring on the board the
question is how he exercises his role
and his judgment and his influence if we
just look to the the current controversy
surrounding Richard Sharp who's chairman
and and you know reports that he helped
facilitate a loan for Boris Johnson
you know the chairman of the BBC has has
almost always been a political
appointment the question is should it be
probably not
um I'd rather not uh I think it's quite
uh interesting to construct a system
which takes you out of the final tours
being made by Downing Street I would be
interested in such a system so the
current system which has been going on
for a long long time and as you rightly
say has produced chairs for more than
one political party nevertheless he's
always going to give you a perception
problem even when the job is done as
scrupulous the impartially as Chris
Patton did it as Roan Affair did it it
was another person I think it was
thought to have conservative leanings
probably did as Gavin Davis did as
Michael Lyons did it is always going to
be a question in people's minds so I
think that the construction of a system
that takes number 10 out of it would be
a good thing now Gary lineker has been
reinstated how do you think those
ministers who are critical of his tweets
will react and how do you think the
right wing press will react so look some
conservative MPS are Furious and will
have wanted the BBC to do something
pretty drastic to Gary lineker that's
always going to be the case but I would
say on the whole
that
some of the reaction to what's happened
here from the right
has not been full-on culture wars I mean
in terms of the way the right wing press
see it well
um let's see
um I mean it's a very good story for
them
um apart from anything else and you
shouldn't underestimate that one of the
things that the BBC does and what you
pay your license fee for you pay for all
the programs and the online content and
all of that and you also pay for the
national entertainment that it gives
when the BBC gets into a bit of a mess I
mean that's not part of the license fee
formally but honestly it's such a
national talking point that everybody
joins in so from the point of view of
the newspapers it makes tremendous copy
get that and it's unlikely the domain on
the telegraph will ever be sympathetic
to the BBC almost no matter what it does
uh the question is you're faced with the
Dilemma that Tim Davey has trying to run
an impartial news organization which by
the way is pretty good in fact in my
view exceptionally good at providing
impartial news and current affairs to
its many audiences and you've got to
wrestle with this rather tricky problem
which is what do you do about people who
aren't in news who nevertheless want to
express themselves very strongly on
Twitter does it or does it not
contaminate the BBC brand overall that
sounds like the exam question uh I'm you
know I'm sure the Daily Mail feels that
it's got an answer and the telegraph's
got an answer and the guardian's got an
answer and the time's got an answer
they're not the same answer it's quite
difficult actually to get it all sorted
and that's what Tim's got to do they've
got this independent person coming in
from outside at this point I don't know
who and we'll see what they come out
with at the end and they may well choose
to stick to the current guideline or
they may alter it or they may abolish it
and then Gary lindick could make a
decision about whether or not
he feels that he can stay in the BBC and
exercise his conscience and his
willingness to contribute to the
National debate to his 8.9 million
Twitter followers the far bigger crisis
for the BBC perhaps in the last week is
that it's called into question their
independence what's your take on all of
that
yeah not for the first time and not for
the last time but the BBC's is
surrounded by political debate
governments of the day have never
particularly liked the BBC and the BBC
despite everybody often perceiving that
it's got this weakness all that weakness
on the whole I think the BBC has done a
pretty Splendid job
in recent years in being able to ward
off these kind of pressures but if you
have a strong opinion in One Direction
or another of a strong flavor you're
very often going to end up being
suspicious of where the BBC stands and
looking back now you know with your
depth of experience do you think the BBC
has compromised
um in instances when it comes to its
independence due to this government
pressure that you describe yeah well I
mean you go right about the beginning
this shows you there was no Golden Age
by the way and it's an important point
because some people albeit of the older
kind of generations think oh you know
Lord wreath or World War II and you know
once BBC was noble and scrupulously
impartial uh to heck with that I mean if
you go back to Lord Ruth he was many
things he was a monster he had one
particular genius which was to come up
with the idea that you know the BBC
would be owned by the public and not my
shareholders and all that sort of stuff
brilliant I'm internally grateful to him
for that but you know Lord wreath was
absolutely not an impartial head of the
BBC thank you very much uh and BBC did a
very good job in World War II but I can
tell you that they were treading all
over JP priestley's talks and it wasn't
as scrupulous as some people might think
uh and on and on it goes so the notion
there was a golden age of impartiality
and that in some way now the BBC is
being weak and feeble feeble in the
teeth of opposing political forces is
not true I think the BBC is better at
all of this than it used to be the case
and I'm not saying it doesn't make the
occasional impartiality error I can
think of some some one or two moments in
the brexit debate where I thought
economists who were making the probe
exit case weren't sufficiently
challenged and so on and so forth so we
can all have our little moments and our
little gripes but I'm asking you know
the audience to this podcast to step
back a bit and take a rounded View and
my rounded view is both as producer and
consumer it does an incredibly good job
for the vast majority of its audiences
for the vast majority of the time
now they've announced this independent
review to look at social media
guidelines
what what should that review look like
in your opinion and who should be
overseeing it my view is that quite a
lot of people should be spoken to
um it's obviously not going to be just
Gary
and Tim Davie I mean I think that the
BBC's presenters both freelance
presenters and non-freelance presenters
are going to be worth listening to
and I think both inside news and not
news or to be listened to
I think that ofcom the regulator needs
to be kept in the loop and I would say
that the audience needs to be listened
to now in saying that the audience is
not a lump of one thing the audience
will point in many different directions
and I don't think that's a bad thing
either because it will show everybody
the complexity of the issue I'm not one
of those who thinks it's simple when I
was on the BBC trust we commissioned
reasonably regularly
audience surveys to find out about
audience views of various things
including by the way partiality but many
other things and we were able to make
sense of it I mean we employed the
appropriate companies to do it opinion
poll companies focus groups companies
qualitative research companies and we
made some sense of it even though not
everybody agreed so I hope that the
audience is involved in all of this uh
because in the end the exam question as
I suggested at the beginning you're
trying to answer is whether tweets which
are not part of the BBC's output not
done by a BBC News presenter or reporter
but very very strongly expressed
do or do not harm the BBC's overall
ability to be
an impartial broadcaster either in
reality or the perception thereof now
that's the question not so easy to
answer so let the audience come into
this and see what they make of it
publish all of that with all its
messiness because it won't be
straightforward and then somebody has to
grip it it'll be the BBC and take a view
about this guideline but whether they
want to keep it change it or abolish it
and then Gary deneka and the BBC sit
down and decide whether that's good
enough for them to go on when it comes
to the BBC's impartiality and
Independence
can it ever get it right so on air which
is what counts for its audiences who are
its owners all of you who pay the
license fee
it does get it right on an extremely
consistent basis across many channels
pretty well all the time that's my view
it may not be you know everybody's view
I understand that but that is what I
think by the way I think it makes
mistakes in impartiality from time to
time as well and on more than one side
as I tried to indicate earlier the
political environment is always testing
both from the left and the right I mean
you know Boris Johnson and uh you know
Liz trust for the brief time that she
was there and you know various others
before and doubtless after have made
life as complicated as they can for the
BBC whilst professing their undying
admiration and love for a treasured
National Institution I mean Boris
Johnson would say on Tuesday oh you know
the BBC the most valued treasured
National Institution on Wednesday he
would try to do all that he could to
raise doubts about the BBC's
impartiality and he wasn't doing that
because of his love of impartiality he
was doing it because it was in his
interest so it's a pretty difficult
environment and by the way you know
labor governments all the rest of it
that's just the the world in which the
BBC lives but for its audiences the
answer question is yeah I think you can
get it right and does get it right most
of the time
my thanks to Mark damaszem and Professor
Susan Franks and to you for listening to
the Sky News Daily with me Sally
Lockwood this episode was produced by
Emma Ray Woodhouse with Alex Eden our
editor is Philly Beaumont